i got a sponsor to cover the whole amc
theater
so
i made all profit and i sold so much and
that night alone i did like 9 000.
when should new filmmakers expect to
make money
from their movies it's up to them um
when i first got in the game i started
out the door i said if i want to make
this film i'm going to rent out venues
i'm going to sell because i already had
that mindset from the music business now
some filmmakers don't have the
experience
so
if you're new and you don't know
for now just make some films until you
comfortable and then learn the business
take baby steps so if you do a short
film that's 10 minutes you know there's
tons of areas you could rent out you
even do a parking lot now do drive to
that's not that much money so just you
just want to create
you want to start a pattern of not to
put out free product
because then no one won't pay for it
you think that by putting a price tag on
it it creates a value
yes yes because
sometimes we have friends and family oh
i want to get a free ticket i want to
get free free free
and then your whole after a while you in
the free zone
it's okay the first time second time but
you guys say your friends and family
know listen this is my passion respect
my job
there's no difference i have a store if
you go to any of the store you're going
to pay for a shirt like everybody else
pay for my product don't do it because
you my friends and family it's 20
you spend all that in the ubs
so yeah you pay you respect my craft
and with the short filmmakers that you
brought in were you giving a cut to
everybody yes i took care of them yeah
okay so that's another thing too i mean
not big cut because i'm the boss but um
but yeah that's another way to get a new
audience in so if you have a short film
you might not have a lot of people to
come then another filmmaker come
together so you have to broken your
orders
and together and build together no
different than so the mindset too
go back to our music business if you go
on tour
you have other acts
everybody bring everybody bringing their
friends and family so we could all work
together and have a fun time
so each showing there were four showings
a day with this night and 900 a day wow
yeah that's actually that's a really
good price yeah that's back in the day
now it's not oh yeah yeah that's what
i'm just trying to see if today
today you could do it um so
let's talk about something more recent
before kovit i did a premiere for my
film lola
and i did 30 hours a ticket
um i got a sponsor to cover the whole
amc data
so
i made all profit and i sold so much and
that night alone i did like 9 000.
and may ask how did you find the sponsor
um once you start building your brand up
people start coming so i've been doing
this for a while
and i had a friend that had a shoes i
want to help you on a sponsor so it's
like the more you invest in yourself the
more people invest in you
so it wasn't like overnight i knew
people i was meeting people hearing it
so they want to invest in me so they
sponsor the whole venue for me what was
in it for them
[Music]
i always helped them do stuff sometimes
i put their clothes in my film so it was
like oh okay
i'm big on helping people so now people
just want to help me make him once even
the best position they can possible okay
so you had already built this
relationship
so i'm big on nurturing relationships a
lot of times in the industry
people don't want to nurture
relationships if they have a value or
unless you could get something
sometimes you got to build a
relationship nurture a relationship
because someone won't have nothing to
help you now when they can help you a
year from now so a lot of times you want
to oh you can't do that for me that's it
no nurture relationships you don't know
where it's going to take you
okay so if you hadn't had that sponsor
though then it would have been a totally
different yeah
i would probably um pay for it myself
okay um but it's sponsors out there but
if you don't got paid for it for
yourself it did as i did this before i
paid for it myself and
stuff like that happened and do you only
do these kind of screenings on like
fridays and saturdays yeah because
that's like the weekend like party
weekend so it might come out because
most people working
you know during the day so i try to do
this fridays saturdays or sundays
so if someone if a theater said you know
what i have this amazing deal it's a
wednesday afternoon
i'm not done it before oh yeah i didn't
make the money i posted
but if you know it depends depends on
the overhead so if i could there to
wednesday it's a cheap deal why not try
it out
and so you make it an event with food
yeah i make it an experience experience
okay so a lot of times like i do raffles
i get do giveaways so i make experience
i don't just just come see my movie i
make it you have fun
so antoine if i buy this ticket and am i
doing i'm online you pre-sale yeah okay
so let's suppose i'm spending thirty
dollars and maybe there's an uh uh
administrative fee on top of that um
what do i get for my ticket did you see
me okay
that's it that's enough okay and you do
raffles so i do i make you like not just
seeing the movie you're gonna get
raffles you're gonna get some food
you're gonna have a great time i just
make it experience get to me some of the
stars of the film
take some pictures i just make
experience i try to you know because
sometimes you go to the movie theaters
and you pay for this money and all you
get was a hundred hundred dollars in
fees and popcorns and everything like
you get to meet the filmmaking to talk
to somebody because i do a q a ask
questions so it's a little more intimate
than going to a big data you just go and
see it and that's it
and do you allow tickets at the door no
so i tell everybody
do pre
let them buy online i mean if it's a
friend they don't have that's different
but try to do pre because then
you could ignore your money in advance
and i'm like oh i don't know how much i
make you get all your money in advance
and then when you do cuddle time so for
example
if your film is next friday
by the week of monday
or tuesday you should know
where your ticket sells at and some
people wait till last minute but online
is better because you know the money
coming in you use some of that money to
pay for something else so always do pre
i don't do door especially now you want
to do everything online
and plus two a lot of people say well oh
yeah i'm there they never showed up and
they never show up you wait she just
wasted a seat so everything's online
cash app everything online okay now
merch is different
merch i do
cash out give me a cash up or if you
have cash i do that but when it comes to
the ticket for the movie it got to be
online but for merch um and sometimes i
do packages
i might have a 50 ticket you might get a
free hoodie a shirt you know you just do
different marketing things to try it out
do people really care about merch yes
why
it's the experience it's no different
than like star wars you get a star wars
thing especially if they know the
filmmaker that's even more experienced
so a lot of times it's my friends my
family my co-workers all coming out they
want me to merge you want to feel cool
and then also you know i have name
actors in my film
that's another experience so all these
little things are just marketing and
knowing the business um
you know sometimes you watch the radio
you only like the song we keep hearing
it a hundred times that's marketing
programming
you ever have a song you keep hearing
how do you like this song we keep
hearing and hearing it
it makes you want to like the song on
the radio it's a marketing program just
like if you go around you see
marvel movies come on friday they got
posters all over the place you keep
seeing it you wasn't even thinking about
seeing it but you keep carrying it and
hearing it that's marketing marketing
program
with the merch are you pre-ordering the
shirt or only cut only to order so if
somebody wants one okay great and then
you send in the order and then it's so
sometimes
right now have a website a little movie
merch they could go online buy it but if
they come to my premiere the march is to
be there
yeah look at the options okay
how do you know because like if you look
at diane von furstenberg with her
amazing wrap dress
the first time
just it was it it put her on the map but
then
another time the the trend had moved on
she'd ordered too much i know now
they've come back but that was the one
thing that just that really taught her
that she ordered too much of her merch
basically so how do we know i don't wear
too much yeah for me i don't have that
problem but
you buy little you buy 50 and see how it
goes so if you buy 20. if it doesn't
sell then you have don't buy a whole
bunch
buy like 20 50. see where is that
and then um you know you test the waters
out
okay so you're not you're you're not
like filling up shelves you're just
doing being very conservative okay
okay
and um
you have it there for people to see at
the screen uh-huh you didn't get on the
website and buy it right so
it's a nice website by the way go there
and buy merch and get right to you
but i mean for these screenings so you
bring oh yeah so i bring
so like for lola i brought like 100
shirts 100 because i knew that the man
was gonna be there and they were all
over
actually i needed more so yeah oh okay
so so it was you you had to take names
down yeah okay
the demand was really big so yeah if you
build it they will come
what about when
people don't buy the merch what what's
behind that
no sale
no but i mean what why
because we we were taught hey get this
merch you know have your own store
but
doesn't always happen yeah i mean it
happens it's like in life you might get
a hundred people to buy it and five
people say no i'm good
no you could do
so just you know you gotta take the good
the good with everything
see
but what do you do to create a desire
for the merch that why we should care
for it what the movie the movie you're
gonna see on social media a lot i'm very
personable so um you know you gotta
cater to your audience
with lola it was you know i have a star
artist and star actors in it um i was
promoting like crazy online
uh it made it at this big festival um
african american uh film festival
permitted so it was so much press going
on
people really loved it merch is it also
the message behind the film yes another
that's another thing woman empowerment a
lot of times you can come up with a
product they got to have a personal
human connection
so this film had a human connection
woman empowerment winter
and my audience could relate to it